Dear six-year-old, training wheels are for babies.
Just let go already.
Regards, a seven-year-old.
Dear seven-year-old, no matter what anyone says, stay weird.
Signed, an eight-year-old.
Dear twelve-year-old, ask her to dance.
Just trust me on this one.
Signed, a sixteen-year-old.
Dear sixteen-year-old, don't let your mom throw away your legos.
Signed, an eighteen-year-old.
Dear eighteen-year-old, go easy on the makeup.
You are not as ugly as you think.
Love, a nineteen-year-old.
Your parents have better interest rates than your credit card.
If he says he has a weekend home in the suburbs, he's married.
That rust protection undercoating, it's actually a great deal.
Whatever you do, never order the salad from a truck stop.
Back up your hard drive.
Now.
I mean, who even does that?
Getting laid off can be a blessing in disguise.
Being a starving artist only works if you actually make art.
Always be kind to your family.
You'll need each other when things get tough.
Always tell the truth.
Except when it comes to your online dating profile.
Dear fifty-one-year-old,...
...one cat is enough cats.
Dear eighty-eight-year-old, cultivate younger friends.
Otherwise, yours will all die off.
Sincerely, ninety-one years old.